herzlich kommt zu einer neuen folge ich
fahre leute wir sind heute in der nähe
von mannheim und wir fahren heute einen
lamborghini uhr ak niveau das ist der
wagen von einem auto das verlangen hast
wenn du gut besetzt
verstehen uns zu
und wenn ich das nicht
[Musik]
wild wild leute also hier sind gerade
eben schon zusammen hierher gefahren ich
mit maxxim auto und kann ich schon so
viel sagen das wird anders
das wird ganz ganz anders als alles was
ich bisher gefahren bin das weiß ich
jetzt schon 640 ps 600 newtonmeter 5,2
liter v10 ist so ein gerät auf jeden
fall
hierbei waren bis zum das auto rom mag
es ganz gerne ein paar sachen zu
erzählen wie bist du auf den wagen
gekommen so was war so also ich sage
euch mal zum kauf animiert hat mich
standard hätte mich damals mal mit
seinem land mitgenommen habe ich mich
direkt verliebt nachdem ihr okay für uns
auch machen und ich glaube er wurde vom
mont angesteckt das kann ja lustig ja
und dann kam es dazu der war
ursprünglich silber der wagen habe ich
jetzt vor kurzem in diesem hellblau
verlieren lassen er würde ich auch sagen
es sehr gelungen die farbe der safe also
not diese farbe weiß ich wie es auf
kamera aussehen aber die ist wie in so
einem tiger musikvideo check dir so
dieses diese wave so das auto fährt so
in ellar um miami irgendein rapper fährt
das so in eltmann hier vorne diese
bremsscheiben an ottakringer darauf
kannst du wirklich nimmt eine pizza
servieren auf diesen brenscheidt keramik
bremsscheiben gigantisch groß dass auch
noch ganz geil ist hier hinten natürlich
einmal die die auspuffrohre sind bei den
performanten bei dem evo hochgesetzt
wenn ich auch sehr neues montiere mich
nachträglich noch diesen diffusor hier
so verlieren lassen diese streifen für
mega geil alter also dass es wirklich
ein krankes auto 305 30 20 zoll hinten
drauf auch schon da sind auch schon
etliche walzen oder allradantrieb
natürlich länger gegen typische und
leute guck mal komm mal guckt erst mal
hier rein durch fenster hier wohnt der
v10 mittelmotor ist noch vor der
hinterachse ist ein mittelmotor hier
sehen wir es nochmal v10 und hier haben
die einfach ordinäre die pension also
sind reihenfolge erzählen da 1 dann 615
dann 27 38 49
das heißt um details kannst du
italienisch oder wusstest du dass das so
bisher italienischer ist ein bisschen
gelernt so krass krawczyk mal ein
türgriff führte also erst mal ich bin
zwar ein bisschen größer leute 190 aber
guck mal wie flach das ding ist und ich
jetzt einmal für euch ein ja einmal also
so das geht bei ungefähr bis zur hüfte
zu achten
sagen wir einmal ein anderes motiv breit
ist aber auch der erste den ich bis
jetzt gesehen hat der kopfhörer
einsteigen ja ich habe so eine komische
art und weise einzusteigen werke ergibt
suche also ich habe über meinen kopf so
so viel platz aber krass hier ganze
optik hier so auf fighter jet guckt euch
einfach nur den start-button ahnt man
startet klappt hoch und dann drücken wir
hier wie in einem jet alter ich würde
sagen wir normalos radegast ja auf jeden
fall in ordentlichen lachs muss man
sagen wir direkt mal klickten machen
guck dir diese knöpfe leute das ist wie
im chat hier das ist fenster einfach
hier ist start stopp und so dass es ist
unrealistisch ja ok aber die erste folge
der format ist immer was bedeuten autos
für dich autos sind für mich sehr
emotional sieht man auch an der wahl von
einem jahr also autokaufs beim immer
etwas emotionales der kann für mich das
beste auto von den werten und daten und
fakten seien aber es muss mich emotional
packen so also bei mir ist das auch mal
wenn ich ein auto abholung bis jetzt
hatte ich habe die freifläche davor
nicht mehr geschlafen so weil ich bin
einfach so vorher davon also in kraft
ich glaube es jetzt auch am meisten von
dem geld was von hinter tatsächlich für
autos ausgegeben
ich bin schon auch auto fliegt vom die
person
das bedeutet
und hey leute es ist wirklich also
dieser wagen auf lamborghini allgemein
aber auch er der frau 10 hier trendiger
das ist einfach auch so ein emotionales
ding das ist einfach geisteskrank das
ist wirklich ein ganz anderes auto also
man denkt vielleicht gerne mal wenn man
jetzt so schnelle porsche gefahren ist
sicher den turbo s von luca 710 kleines
auto wiebels dass man aber dann so dass
ich denke ja dass sein sportwagen ich
erstmal starken sportwagen gefallen ich
kenne das ja ja das hier ist eine ganz
andere nummer
[Musik]
dieser sound liga ein turbolader einfach
sauger 5,2 liter
ganz ehrlich ich würde auch viel lieber
sohn performant fahren als zum beispiel
in urus weisen urus ist so ja so ist
glaube ich nur der motor ist ein v8 den
krieg sie auch bei jeder kriegt bei audi
denkt ist auch ich wollte mir
ursprünglich zuerst ein us holen ja weil
ich so ein bisschen dachte ja hast du
musst dann brauchst du nur ein auto war
das ding ist jetzt bei im jura kann oder
nach event braucht man auch ein alltags
werden sagt ja wir haben auf jeden fall
heißt wenn man sich so ein auto kauft
dann muss man halt noch ein zweites auto
kaufen und deswegen wollte zum ersten
urus holen aber der wagen hat mich
emotional nicht abgeholt ist ein absolut
geiles auto hat auch einen stabilen
sound und ist schnell und komfortabel
und alles aber es ist für mich ihnen
kein lambo ja ok wird das will ich erst
hatte ich zur probefahrt du denkst
einfach ist denn erst gemacht der
bassist von von wyplay das gleiche so
ein hoch motorisierte suv aber du hast
nicht dieses diesen lambo weil das ist
ja auch vw plattform also der immer
cayenne coupé er ist 82 aus dass die
selbe erste plattform und klar
volkswagen denkt sich ja geil ok
lamborghini gehört uns so wie wenn wir
jetzt erster bauen kann man die gleiche
plattform neben für aventador können die
keinen golfplatz es geht nicht das ist
ja eine eigene plattform soll ja das
heißt dadurch ist das ganze konzept
einfach halt lambo so von vorne bis
hinten und nicht so ein bisschen basis
von auch von audi und gut ich sag mal na
klar man man findet auch hier immer mal
wieder so ein paar sachen die man
vielleicht aus dem audi oder so kennt ja
zum beispiel jetzt hier die knöpfe oder
display und so habe ich das auch schon
öfter gehört aber das ist auch bei
bentley gehört es zu diesem vw konzern
aber das auch gut findet wobei ihr habt
ja auch gerade sagen ich finde dass
übels gut weil der wagen hier das habe
ich mich auch für den hunger cannero
entschieden habe
gibt kein sportwagen auf dem level der
auch so ein gutes multimedia system at
mit diesem display wie alles
funktionierte schließt handy an direkt
apple karl bley hier mit touch ist die
lautstärke und so verändern weißt du was
funktioniert so gut also dass du hast
dieses multimedia system und sportwagen
und da gibt es gerade also kein ferrari
oder oder hat es mir auch schon zu
verhalten und so die haben das alle
nicht mehr
das hat jetzt aktuell nur der urheber
und das wird extrem geil das ist nämlich
eine gute sache wenn man quasi so
infotainment und so und anschlüsse
konnektivität aus der großserie nähe von
turin
dies ist einfach 100.000 fach
millionenfach schon gebaut und
perfektioniert haben und dann so motor
und so aus italien hat ja egal diese
aufmerksamkeit ist zu krass sind und
wirklichkeit ist ein kleiner junge hat
sie aus dem auto von seinem bett aus dem
fenster raus gehängt ok wird es keine
rein machen ersten gang
also hier machen auf bremse fuß auf
können ja jetzt erster gang drin also
hier ist ja erst nach einschalten ganz
normal und blinkend hier ist es immer
mal waren bligg chaos ist das so genau
jetzt aber aber das aber ist es nicht so
dass man dann in die mitte drücken muss
damit ausgeht auch das ist ja wie beim
roller roller motorräder haben es auch
so einfach
westerwave no job wirklich wenn hier
unten hast park und rückwärtsgang
genau wie sie also rückwärtsgang muss
man quasi hebel nicht auch die kamera
und jetzt bin ich hier da drücke wieder
wieder erster gang durchsagen machen
wir's mal an die arbeit
das ist so ungewohnt leute den motor die
ihn hinter euch und zwar richtig
motivieren porsche wo er wissen dass
hinter euch und der gut der ist der
sitzt euch wirklich im nacken hier
der schreit euch von
[Musik]
aber also obwohl der so hart es fährt
der sich sehr ruhig also ich dachte
gerade so okay wir fangen jetzt 50 und
schaut drauf sind 90 gefahren also das
ist auch hart man kann den wagen auch
eigentlich voll alltäglich nutzen also
der einstieg ist jetzt sehr tief und so
viel platz aber und das ist jetzt bei
die schaltvorgänge meinen zweiten
[Musik]
ein bisschen respekt davor gewarnt ein
sonderfall ist auch wichtig dass man
davor geschah erst jetzt von beust aber
krass ich ja alles anders
[Musik]
die sache ist leute das ist ja wirklich
so ein wahnsinn bing so also mit man
geht ja sogar der motor schreit einen
von hinten wird es dort am grab selbst
gestaltet war einfach gewartet bis er es
ist er automatisch gesetzt schaltet und
er ist einfach nur drauf denn genau die
kinder und kraß deg der motor schreit
euch wirklich überraschen wenn er
anfängt zu schreien dann ist auch kopf
kannst du gar nicht mehr denken
gesagt mach das ding es hätte auch so
viele leute also das ist das ist
wirklich ein fahrgefühl ist kann man
ganz schön beschreiben einfach so
aggressiv von man sitzt 25 cm wirklich
am boden ist kann nicht viel mehr sein
heftig helfer hier so irgend einem
parkplatz so dürft ihr geben ihre mami
fährt mit dem golf variant einkaufen und
nacht nur zwei jungs im land werde man
mit dem mit dem ta karten vergleicht ja
weil der tag hat ist er schneller ist
als der noch null auf hundert ja ja
genau 100 mir lieber dass auch im
vergleich zu leben weil ich kann mir das
gar nicht vorstellen dass noch was
schnell also der tag hat hat mehr punch
japanischen meerrettich habe 900
newtonmeter drehmoment serie das ist
eine sache die man hier mehr wagen
kannst nicht so brutal wie ein turbo
oder panscht weißkirchen können so das
finde ich dass merck im vergleich zum
tag schon aber der sound leute ist ja
wirklich so viel krasser also der der
turbo s er ist wirklich leise von luca
da geht nicht viel von außen aber der
ist ja nur anschreien junge
die ganze zeit
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
merkst du geil dass ich in der straße
vorbei ist ja ja das auf jeden fall so
fest sogar sind noch leicht um die kurve
dabei und krallt sich so in der straße
das dass das müssen wir auch hier nutzen
wenn sie der ländlichen gegend sind dass
ein bisschen mehr so die kurven so
mitnehmen
[Musik]
die awo also gar kein problem das ist
ein ding hier bei den beiden klassik
meist gar keine sorgen darum das haben
die kurve geht 0 0
er gibt dir die ganze gefühl alles gut
egal ob die tiere um 180 grad drehen mit
100 schweinen geben du bist physikalisch
immer schluss dass man jetzt nicht mit
200 in der gruppe brettert aber man
merkt das schon seit die boden traktion
von dem wagen der allrad und so dass es
schon sehr gut gemacht gibt eine sehr
viel vertrauen muss man wirklich sagen
das ding ist war ja auch noch mit dem
mit dem gleichen wagen auf der
rennstrecke also nicht mit dem aber auch
mit dem berg nebo kino event auf
nürburgring ja dass ich mir zum
instructor umgefahren und da ist man das
auto wirklich vor bis an die grenzen
gefahren auf der rennstrecke habe ich so
bis jetzt auch noch nicht erlebt aber
das ist krass also dolbergs erstmal
viel den wagen eigentlich zutrauen
kannst man auch nicht so im
straßenverkehr natürlich nicht machen
würde aber so auf der rennstrecke dann
dank ist es halt wirklich teilweise mit
115 kurve rein gebrettert
der wagen hat es halt einfach gemacht um
logic das gefühl habe ich auch bei dem
auto wenn man hier so viel hat und so
ein bisschen bis in die kurve legt ganz
easy also der wagen gibt mir auch das
gefühl ich kann noch viel viel mehr und
er gibt mir das gefühl kollege mich
kannst du nur richtig erfahren wenn wir
wirklich auf der rennstrecke sind und
auch keine regel mehr gelten das ist
schon also der der wagen bereit dir mal
20 auf 140
das ist abgeregelt ist bei 340 aber ist
auch echt ein schönes ding also hier
mannheim weinstraße die gegen das sieht
schon sehr sehr nett aus wie südtirol
und dass sie hier auch so auf den vollen
guten platz völlig gefunden das jetzt ja
also ich komme hier auch aus der geht ja
gedacht er mich ja hier aus und am ende
des tages ist auch extrem wichtig
familie
na ja es hat vier jahre in köln nicht
und wenn dann halt mal was ist dann
merkt man halt auch wieder dass man dann
halt allein ist ja das ist schon besser
wir haben 111
das wirklich mich leute hier zusammen
ruft eure mutter ihren vater um europa
wenn also noch ein bisschen öfter hand
vielleicht als das jetzt nicht so kann
jetzt unsere position war halt einfach
viele von uns profitieren wollen er weiß
halt eigentlich fast nur bei deiner von
julia vielleicht bei einer wirklichen
kindheits freundin weißt du dass dies
wirklich nur gut mit ihr meinen besten
wir haben bei allen anderen denkst du
mal die wollen von ihr profitieren und
presse ja noc und bei jungs ist so ein
ding und gerade bei mädels ist es auch
kraß finde ich also thema frauen so ja
genau
also das ist wollte ich einfach zu
trennen kranken krank rang das ist
wirklich ich finds geil hier die ganzen
details auch dass die jetzt hinten die
zünd reihenfolge draufschreiben oder
sowas ist ganz die ganzen kleinen
italienischen sachen ja dadurch auch zum
zum einjährigen geburtstag vor dem neuen
buch ja habe das kann ich dir gleich mal
zu hause zeigen da habe ich mir so in
seine acrylglas diesen diesen metall
patch der auch hinten traut es mit der
zweiten folge mit der unterschrift von
im nabu kind wie bekommt man da so geil
das kriegt man so als einjähriges
geburtstagsgast auch eine geile sache
es ist wirklich eine erfahrung labor ist
wirklich eine erfahrung muss man echt
sagen er hat also man muss auch sagen so
in der bikini macht sich wirklich auf
viele gedanken um die kunden wie gesagt
hier diese rennen event was ich gesagt
habe oder ich habe neulich zu einem
riesenboxer geschickt bekommen mit mit
mirabal weinbar da drinnen so olivenöl
so gut ist und so also die schicken das
sachen laden ein auf event sein und so
das wirklich schon so du hast das gefühl
werden als lucchini konnte wirst du
schon so nice behandelt weil sie ja fast
das weiße teil von seiner familie als
sogar klar an der klar der fall am ball
fahrer nicht mehr an die kümmert sich
alle um dann der heftigkeit also das
kenne ich auch es ist wirklich egal wo
man lang fährt jeder dreht ist einfach
unfair diesen auto der stadt aber
gefilmt
normalerweise gut aber so kennen die
blaue lambos halt auf der sticht ins
auge
es ist wirklich schon eine ganz absurde
erfahrungen hier so dicht diese dörfchen
hier zu fahren und alle starren einen an
wirklich ne als hätte ich drei arme zu
gucken nämlich an noten gucken jetzt
[Gelächter]
einfach drauf gehabt hast das geschäft
beleben ich hoffe dann hat das in dem
video gesehen einfach dieser oper hatte
sondern mit dieser elf kette müssen was
soll ich sagen ja genau also wenn du
größter bis müsste man sich dann schon
so eine band adoro holen darf man dann
wieder mehr an der playa und jetzt leute
autobahn gekommen
ich sehe ich ja nicht mehr verlassen
kann links rechts autos kommerz bedeutet
es natürlich hier so ein bisschen den
wagen so ein bisschen fühlen
andererseits kann ich verstehen dass
dort auch schütz das ganze war kein
problem
ok dann weißt du nicht
und bevor egal welches auch das
komplette ober nasen gut bekommen sollte
kommen wir zur bewertung der ersten
kategorie haben wir natürlich wie immer
das aussehen der lambo ist sexy essen
richtige exot flach laut einfach bild
ich wollte ja nicht von 10 geben weil
ich mir dachte okay irgendwie optisch
vielleicht dann der der porsche von luca
dann doch irgendwie mehr aber für die
ganzen details diese detailverliebtheit
diese sind reihenfolge hinten die
fensterscheibe durch die man den motor
sieht gebe ich nur verzehren die
beschleunigung des wagens brutal 2,9
sekunden von null auf hundert unterhalt
ist ganz klar mit dem miro alles unter
drei sekunden von 0 auf 100 mussten zehn
von zehn gehen und ganz ehrlich leute
genauso verhält sich bei der coolness
der lambo ist einfach ein wildes lautes
extrovertiertes autor ist ein exot jeder
mensch dreht sich um die leute machen
fotos hier muss es in der kategorie
coolness die ganz ganz seltenen 10 von
10 gigabit der kofferraum ist unfassbar
klein hat keine zweite sitzreihe hin
man muss ultra tief unten reimann sieht
ganz wenig der verbraucher es hoch zwei
von zehn gleich ob es bei sauber auto
natürlich wieder ein bisschen absurd
220.000 euro basispreis dazu noch ein
paar extras ja das tut weh
viertelmillion kann man schon grob
gerechnet dafür ist der lärm und
brutaler sportwagen aber eben auch nur
das ist weniger alltagstauglich als
beispiel einen elfer und deswegen muss
hier weniger punkte geben als bei lukas
turbo s 15 hatte lukas auto deswegen
jetzt hier vier von zehn und zu guter
letzt sollte beim komfort habe ich mich
wirklich barmherzig gezeigt und gebt dem
lambo drei von zehn und ich glaube da
kommt er ganz gut weg das ist kein
komfortables auto muss man einfach so
sagen insgesamt kommen damit auf 38 von
60 punkten
wir sind jetzt hier auf dem bildschirm
noch mal wie der lambo gegen die anderen
autos die schon getestet habe
abschneidet das war es an dieser stelle
ich bin sehr gespannt auf den nächsten
sonntag abonniert gerne main kanal
gefallen hat und macht's gut